يتعمق البنتاغون في الأمر مع قيام
حارس المرمى إيلون ماسك
بإعطاء شركة الفضاء الخاصة التي يمتلكها ماسك
SpaceX عقدًا يصل إلى 1.2 مليار دولار
لإرسال أقمار صناعية تجسس سرية إلى
الفضاء، لكن هذا ليس كل ما في الأمر، حيث
يستثمر البنتاغون أيضًا ما يصل إلى 70 مليون دولار في ستار
شيلد، وهي وسيلة أكثر أمانًا.  نسخة من كوكبة سبيس إكس
الضخمة من
أقمار ستارلينك الصناعية والتي تعتبر حيوية للنجاح
العسكري الأوكراني ضد روسيا
في
ساحة المعركة يمكنني أن أؤكد أننا قمنا
بالتعاقد مع ستارلينك للخدمات والدعم
لأوكرانيا أه مع
الهدف النهائي وهو ضمان حصول أوكرانيا
على الاتصالات عبر الأقمار الصناعية
البنية التحتية التي تحتاجها ولم
تتمكن ناسا من إرسال رائد فضاء آخر إلى
القمر بدون شركة إيلون ماسك
ماسك ستارشيب هو
أقوى صاروخ تم بناؤه على الإطلاق وقد
أطلق في رحلته التجريبية الثانية يوم
السبت وستنفق ناسا حوالي 4
مليارات دولار عليه لأنه سيكون  من
المحتمل أن تكون مركبة الهبوط القمرية لبرنامج Flagship Artemis التابع لوكالة الفضاء هي
الفرصة الوحيدة لأمريكا للتغلب على الصين إلى
القمر في سباق الفضاء الثاني هذا،
وتعتمد ناسا أيضًا على
SpaceX لإطلاق رواد فضاء إلى
محطة الفضاء الدولية في الوقت الحالي، ولا يوجد
مزود إطلاق آخر  بخلاف ما
تستطيع الحكومة الروسية القيام به، فإن SpaceX
في المقدمة لأنهم فعلوا أفضل ما في الأمر.
دوج لاو هو أحد الأشخاص القلائل الذين
كانوا مسؤولين رفيعي المستوى في الوكالتين
الحكوميتين الأكثر اعتمادًا على
شركات إيلون ماسك، ويصف
وكالة ناسا بأنها أكثر من ذلك بكثير.  يعتمدون على
SpaceX أكثر من البنتاغون، SpaceX هي
المهيمنة في الوقت الحالي ولكنها ليست بأي
حال من الأحوال الاحتكار الذي سنعتمد
عليه جميعًا بينما الولايات المتحدة لديها
شركاء آخرون، لقد كان SpaceX يمكن الاعتماد عليه في
عمل خطير قد يفسر
سبب استمرارهم في العمل معهم.  المسك الذي
أدانه البيت الأبيض
لنشره رسائل معادية للسامية
العام الماضي، أجرت الولايات المتحدة 78
عملية إطلاق ناجحة وكانت SpaceX
مسؤولة عن 61 منها، وهو
نفس عدد عمليات الإطلاق التي قامت بها
الحكومة الصينية وما يقرب من ثمانية أضعاف
كمية أقرب مركبة SpaceX.  المنافس الأمريكي
United Launch Alliance، وهو
مشروع مشترك بين Boeing وMartin المقفل
هذا العام، قد تجاوز SpaceX بالفعل هذا
الرقم القياسي مع 85 عملية إطلاق مدارية،
ويتزايد العدد في الوقت الحالي وفي المستقبل القريب،
ويرتبط وصول الحكومة الأمريكية إلى الفضاء بشكل كبير بـ SpaceX
والمتحدث باسم البيت الأبيض.  وقال يوم الاثنين إنه
ليس على علم بأي جهود لتغيير
ذلك